matcom cinq entités dans lesquelles entrer
nécessite un mot
Je me rends compte que mon chien est toujours dans le
feu et qu'il est alors trop tard les murs se
sont effondrés le toit s'est effondré
et d'autres se souviennent juste avoir laissé échapper
cet horrible cri toute mon
identité a été dépouillée  J'ai perdu
tout mon équipement de communication J'ai tout perdu
et je suis juste assis
là à penser à ce que je ferai ensuite en
grandissant dans l'Utah J'ai passé beaucoup de temps
dans le désert J'ai toujours été
fasciné par ça J'ai décidé  pour vivre à
distance en Alaska il y a des années, je
devais vraiment m'éloigner de tout cela,
m'éloigner de la course effrénée de
la bureaucratie de la circulation tout ça Je possède
deux parcelles
J'ai trouvé la première parcelle en
2018 et c'était difficile il a fallu  sept
jours pour y aller à pied depuis la portion que
je devais atterrir après avoir volé vers un lac J'y suis
resté un mois dans cette nouvelle
propriété J'ai rencontré un gars qui était un ancien
vétérinaire du Vietnam et il n'avait pas vu de gens qu'il
n'avait pas  avait des voisins pour vraiment lo  ng
temps donc il était super bavard super
accueillant il avait une configuration incroyable il avait des
serres et il cultivait toute sa propre nourriture
et des tonnes de tabac donc je me suis vraiment
connecté avec lui mais il était plus âgé il
avait 78 ans à l'époque et il est mort en  l'
été 2019 la propriété est allée à sa
famille mais je suis devenu en quelque sorte le premier
à l'acheter j'ai pu
acheter qu'en septembre j'ai déménagé là-bas à
plein temps car il était là
depuis 20 ans l'incendie s'est déclenché quand j'ai
surchargé  le poêle à bois tard dans la nuit
un morceau de carton brûlant a volé dans la
cheminée et a atterri sur une partie du
toit qui avait du plastique et qui a enflammé une
coque apparaît dans le plafond légèrement
au-dessus de mon lit lui-même et c'est le trou qui
dégouline de feu et de plat  comme des
gouttes de feu en plastique, je vais juste chercher de l'
eau, je la jette au plafond,
je prends l'extincteur et à ma grande consternation, je
tire sur la goupille et j'essaie de la pousser
et rien ne sort, alors j'ai commencé à
paniquer un peu.  point je vais
dehors pour attraper de la neige et c'est à ce
moment-là que j'ai réalisé que tout le toit
au-dessus de mon lit du côté est de ma
maison est couvert de flammes et qu'il
grandit rapidement ma première pensée est de sauver
mon chien et de prendre du matériel de survie j'essaie
d'exhorter mon  chien hors du lit il est
terrifié
blotti dans un coin et il pèse 110
livres donc il est impossible de le soulever
et de le porter je le pousse enfin
hors du lit et il échappe à ma vision
je pense qu'il m'a quitté mais je  Je ne peux pas
dire parce qu'il y a tellement de feu tout
autour de moi et que le toit s'effondrait à
ce moment-là et mes derniers soupirs, je dois
attraper mon fusil qui est du côté ouest de
la maison, alors je cours pour l'attraper et
c'est là que je me rends compte que  mon chien est
toujours dans le feu et à ce moment-là, il est trop
tard les murs se sont effondrés le toit
s'est effondré et tout ce dont je me souviens, c'est juste d'
avoir laissé échapper cet horrible cri
toute mon identité a été dépouillée j'ai
perdu tout mon équipement de communication je '
J'ai tout perdu et je suis juste assis  ting
là va couler que dois-je faire ensuite
le feu a commencé à 1h00 du matin
je travaille je travaille jusqu'à environ 10h00 du
matin essayant d'éteindre ce feu quand
je l'ai finalement éteint j'ai fait un inventaire
de ma nourriture  et je n'ai eu qu'une boîte pour le
petit-déjeuner et une pour le dîner pendant
environ 3035 jours. Je savais maintenant après l'
incendie qu'il y avait au moins 10 jours
avant que quelqu'un ne commence à
s'inquiéter. Je savais que j'avais besoin d'un abri, alors je suis
immédiatement allé à la construction d'un  petite
grotte de neige ça rentrerait juste dans mon corps en
mettant un SOS dans la neige Je l'ai fait
vers peut-être le huitième jour Je savais que personne
n'allait venir me chercher à cause de
cette ligne de temps que j'avais manquée et les
gens n'allaient même pas  être inquiet
pour moi dire peut-être deux semaines plus tard, j'avais un
plan de communication en vigueur que si je
manquais mes communications régulières, mon
pilote privé serait appelé et il
ferait un survol pour s'assurer que je vais
bien,
j'ai trouvé beaucoup de réconfort dans  à la recherche de la
beauté et des choses malgré tout donc
je  a été récupéré le 9 janvier sur la
recommandation des pilotes parce qu'il faisait si
froid pour voler pour lui, il était occupé par
beaucoup d'autres choses dans sa vie, a-t-il dit
, contactons les Alaska State
Troopers, ils seront une meilleure
option à ce  point c'est que ça n'a pas l'
air bien pendant cette période de froid
que nous avons J'ai entendu l'hélicoptère
j'ai attrapé mes bottes me suis précipité dehors
et j'ai commencé à faire le signe de la main je les ai
dirigés vers ma piste d'atterrissage où ils
pourraient atterrir et à partir de là j'ai attrapé
juste un  peu de choses c'était c'était
des sentiments très très mitigés quand cet hélicoptère
est arrivé j'étais j'étais reconnaissant que
quelqu'un soit enfin là et que
je reverrais un visage humain j'étais triste
trop surtout triste de laisser mon chien derrière
sans un enterrement approprié et ainsi de suite  et
puis c'était dur c'était dur de voler
dans l'hélicoptère et de voir toute ma
propriété et c'est ma maison et j'étais je le
quittais les gens ne comprennent pas
toute l'histoire et pensent que oh c'est juste
un autre gars qui s'en va  un caprice non je
passe de nombreuses années et plusieurs milliers de
dollars à m'assurer que j'étais en sécurité et que
quelque chose s'est mal passé
il est encore difficile de
voir ces images les images reviennent
ma capacité à rester heureux trouver de l'humour et des
choses et rire chanter des chansons ça
m'a vraiment gardé en vie